the first ride is the straight wall ride
the second act is our go-kart so it's
four wheels this time
it's right in one of these lovely ladies
and when you do hands off
stand it up hands off sitting on the
sides standing on the side as a whole
array of acts it's an experience you
can't prepare anything in the world too
I'm Kerry Cameron and iron wall of death
Rider and I ride for Luke Fox's original
wall of death I started riding the wall
of death by pure accident I used to work
with horses and unfortunately where I
was working in the place shut down
so naturally we went to the Jobcentre
and I just typed in horse rider into the
search engine and we'll a deaf rider
came up and I went down to the art and
they had the wall boot up I knew there
and then that was it
you do you're very dizzy when you're
first going to ride because you've got
buildings down there up to the dizziness
you have to go at least first email out
to stay on with of wise gravity will
just whip you straight off it's a
mixture free thing so balance speed and
I'll see a bit of stamina just lifting
your arm up it's a way of good bias the
audience is quite a feat it's a good
feeling being a female rider in this
masculine vironment it gives me a great
buzz because a lot of people when they
see you walk into the wall they just
think they're a bit of flash you know
but as soon as they see you get on the
bike you can hear like murmurs saying oh
there's a girl on a motorbike see all
their faces light up and then after the
show all the girls they're like wow
you've got bigger balls and roses and
then but but it's great to know that
they're looking you thinking bully if
you could do it then
[Music]